so
i come from bosnia
i mean i live in sweden now but you
don't need to know my whole life story
but the story that i do want to share is
from my home country so close to 50
percent of the land in bosnia is
dedicated to agriculture and farming
so the government decides to support
farmers to set up the budget to set up
the requirements for the people to
receive the budget and then to disperse
the funds
so they do that and towards the end of
the process they decide to analyze who
really received these funds
and they did that and the ministry of
agriculture was shocked
because only one group of citizens
received 90
of these funds
and those were men
men working in agriculture
so
where were the women why didn't they
have access to the funds
the ministry of agriculture was
surprised because they didn't mean to
discriminate they knew they were women
working in agriculture right so they
went back and analyzed the situation and
the problem was well there were three
things the first thing is they didn't
even know the gender of farmers because
they've never done gender analysis
before so actually they did know the sex
the segregation of cows but not of
people
i will let that sing a bit because
gender is unimportant
the second issue is that the way they
were distributing the funds could
possibly not reach women why because
one of the condition was to get this
subsidy was to give out a land ownership
certificate and we know that
traditionally women do not land and the
second problem was that women didn't
even know why because the information
was shared and for us that they do not
participate in
but the story has a happy end because
when the ministry realized this they
changed these provisions and with the
help of gender experts from bosnia we
now see more and more women getting
funds every year
so what is the point of this story
the point is not only that we should
have sex disaggregated date on people
not only
cows
but it's also that we can budget fair
and equitably
but we can't just run numbers blindly
we need to know the faces of people that
we are serving with public funds
so this is really the heart of gender
responsive budgeting
or as i like to think of it and maybe
you too common sense budgeting
so i am economist i work with public
finance so public finance and budgets
but my specialty
is helping governments inject gender
perspective in their financial decisions
and budgets
okay so budgets are fairly simple
straightforward as it was introduced and
now you're thinking well that does not
look fairly straightforward and it's
intentionally done like that
because this is how we often imagine the
budget to be so complex so technocratic
bureaucratic we don't even want to
engage
but the reality is very different than
that in fact all our budgets being it
your own budgets or public budgets or
company budgets go through the four
logical steps
the first step is of course we are
calculating our revenues in the sense of
the state it would be taxes and fees
right
the second step is budget approval after
we figure what we will do with the funds
it goes to the approval of the
parliament
and then the third step my personal
favorite is spending
or budget execution
ideally according to priorities not my
personal favorite and then we go into
control and budget oversight so whether
we have actually spent
the money as we planned and also whether
we have achieved the objectives
so in the sense of the state it would be
increased level of education decreased
level of poverty in the sense of the
company it would be profit or income you
see where i'm going so what is really
wrong with that it sounds perfectly
logical well what is wrong with that is
that traditionally in most of the
countries if not all around the world we
assume when we are planning the budget
funds that we are targeting one
universal homogeneous human
that will have the same access to funds
the same needs almost
and then the situation such as this one
in ministry of agriculture happens then
we are surprised that our funds didn't
really reach everybody
so what i want to also say here
what do we then do about that
in ukraine the government has analyzed
close to 300 budget programs and when i
say budget programs these are
expenditures in health education sports
infrastructure defense anything you can
think of that is funded with public
funds
and in every single one of these
programs
we have found gender gaps
we have found big gender gaps and these
gender gaps were usually on account of
women they didn't have access
and why did this happen it happened
because finance officers were just doing
their job and they were doing it really
well
they were planning for economic
effectiveness efficiency value for money
we really love value for money
performance budgeting medium-term
all of these
very valid economic objectives very
valid goals but we really didn't account
for the needs of people that we are
serving with these funds and let me
illustrate that
so we have analyzed the program from
tuberculosis
so treatment of patients of tuberculosis
and you may be now asking
okay but you know you need to treat the
patient why is gender important there
but when we have done the analysis we
have actually seen that 70
of the patients of tuberculosis were men
and this is tuberculosis is a big issue
in ukraine and these were men living in
remote areas in rural areas working in
mines however the preventive measures
and the way they were designed they
didn't account for it
they were actually targeting those
sectors such as education and health
where women traditionally dominate and
this is fine but they really didn't
account for the needs of these men in
the risk groups and why
because gender equality was not
important in the budget decision
so what i'm trying to illustrate here is
that not only that we need
to account for gender equality to
achieve our objectives of equality but
we also need to account for it to make
more common sense budgetary decisions
more effective and efficient budgets so
how do we do that it looks equally
entertaining but now we also add gender
so it's a total mess and we would think
how do we even go about that but of
course it's not as complex as that
because in the heart
of this work is gender analysis
and what do i mean by that
so when we are planning as finance
officers any financial or fiscal
decision meaning when we are planning
introducing new tax for example
the core is to analyze how will that
influence
different groups in a society
so will we have our gender gaps
increased
we don't want to do that
reduced or leave the status quo
so of course we want to reduce them and
i just want to put it here as well
in most of the countries not all
unfortunately but in a lot of countries
around the world we have a very solid
legislative framework for gender
equality we have commitments but when it
comes to budget and finance that's where
suddenly the story evaporates
so when it comes to money it's not
really analyzed for a gender impact so
this is really important and we do this
in
as i said three steps i will take you
very fast through these steps don't
worry
so the first step is really to do
situation analysis
so in our agriculture example if we had
done situation analysis and we if we had
known
gender gaps in this sector we wouldn't
have been surprised we would have known
that women do not owe land so we
wouldn't give this as a requirement and
we would definitely have known
that we need to inform them in different
way so this is the first step the second
step is related to my example with sex
desegregation you will remember from the
beginning so we really need to know the
beneficiaries that we are trying to
serve and now you are thinking this
sounds very obvious but it's not done
and the third step of course is to know
the procedures
how will we give this budget out who
will have the access what will be the
excluded groups
and that's it
and now i will just share
some good news i think
is that around 80 countries around the
world are working with gender budgeting
and please if you
have an interest just see if your own
country is one of them
but when i say they are working with
gender budgeting that does not mean that
their whole budget is gender responsive
that would be my dream
but my personal hero is austria why
because they have gender budgeting
entrenched in constitution so that means
that in austria it cannot happen that
you have an investment project that you
are doing without considering gender and
gender equality
canada feminist government gender
balance cabinet and they are doing
gender budgeting but they are taking
into account needs of indigenous groups
of people so this is also something that
we want to do and we have to do
morocco let us let me take you to
morocco morocco is working with gender
budgeting for 20 years
indonesia with the help of the world
bank has just analyzed their whole
budget system
to make it more gender responsive and i
need to take you again to bosnia because
i did start with that example
balkan countries are doing fantastic
work with the help of you and women so
there is a lot of work happening and i'm
now coming to an end
because you might be now wondering okay
but
what is in it for me in a sense you're
talking about public budgets but i work
in a company or ngo or i'm self-employed
doesn't matter
so what is it why is it important for us
because this is our money these are our
budgets we are feeling these budgets
it's not some abstract
money out there so we have the right to
demand it to be equitable
to be fair
that's one thing so it is important for
the countries it's important for the
companies
of course we should ask who is making
decisions whose needs are being
satisfied and also maybe families but
who really has
the voice who is making decisions
it's interesting just to see and then to
uh maybe be surprised as these
ministries or not
so
if you are interested you are literally
one click away and i'm aware this sounds
like a
sales pitch but i am selling
you
the work of many many gender budgeting
experts around the world who have been
for years working with these concepts so
you have such a wealth of material from
you and women
imf different scholars world bank
swedish government doesn't matter i will
not go into all the wealth of materials
so it's all out there
and if we do that
we will have the budgets that will not
only lead
to gender equality which is amazing
objectives in itself but we will have
better
more effective more efficient more fair
budgets what's not to like
so i hope
next time we meet maybe here
again this type of gender responsive
budgeting will be called
budgeting
thank you